this is wild to me slide 58.
what are our buddies what you are saying
is that the drivers of populism
put the united states from a political
risk standpoint
the same as a emerging market there is
no developed nation united states when
it comes to the political risk so
explain what is going on here
yeah so let me just i mean just without
even explaining what the chart is
signifying just look at our homies like
look at the guys and gals we're hanging
out with in this chart it's not like
france and korea and japan like our
developed market homies it's russia and
china people will hack us on a regular
basis in chile and mexico like it this
is it's it's bonkers so this the x-axis
on this chart says the genie coefficient
that's a measure of income dispersion
higher is more any unequal uh lower is
more equal and the y-axis in this
charter shows unemployment rate and so
you think about unequal societies that
are you know have high levels of
unemployment that tends to be where you
get the highest amount of political risk
uh in the economy and as a function of
that and sorry one of the reasons
for the location of our dot the reason
our dot is in that location is on flight
59.
you know so like the we've had all
we've had a war against you know
middle-class and low class lower middle
income and lower income people in this
in this society for the past kind of 20
plus years the blue line and this shark
shows employee compensation as a percent
of national income and the red line just
shows corporate profits as a percent of
national income and obviously that was a
long healthy stable relationship it was
cyclical but it was pretty stable for
you know kind of 50 years and then over
the last 20 years or so it's kind of
really reversed on its head and you know
why has it reversed on its head well
there's kind of three big factors one
obviously globalization trying to join
the wto in 2001 was obviously a big
factor there you have obviously the
advent of technology and digitization in
the economy but i would think one of the
the least talked about factors is really
kind of the explosion and the growth of
the private equity industry and the
industry consolidation we've seen as a
function of that and all the m and
associated with that and so really we've
gotten to the point in this chart where
it's like it's just politically
unfeasible not to address this the
situation obviously we had you know
black lives matter we had black people
protesting in the spring we had angry
white people protested in january and
guess what they're on both sides
of the political aisle it's not about
democrats or republicans it's about
angry poor people we've created a very
large amount of angry poor people in
america and as much as we try to ignore
that as people operating in and around
wall street the fact of the matter is
they haven't gone anywhere and so the in
our and my sort of thesis on this is
that if you go back to the next slide is
that's why we're panicking from a fiscal
policy perspective
albeit less so than we were at the onset
of the pandemic but we're certainly
still panicking that next slide shows
that the scatter plot shows the x-axis
is the current account uh a surplus for
deficit as a percentage gdp the y-axis
shows the uh sovereign fiscal balances
and percent of gdp and the reality is is
our dot is at the bottom left for a
reason like we are panicking as a fiscal
fiscal authority in response to not just
covet because covet was an accelerant to
some of these dynamics right like covet
made poor people poor it made people of
color even more poor on a relative basis
than they already were and so it really
was an accelerant and so that's why we
you see us drop our dot and this chart
all the way down to the bottom left well
you kind of round up this entire
discussion the next couple of the charts
kind of just kind of get to the real
heart of the matter which is why i think
the inflation rate is likely to be
persistent over the long term you go to
slide 60 uh 60 through 62 kind of just
get to the real they answer the question
really quickly who's going to pay the
bill
uh slide 61 says the foreigners aren't
going to pay the damn bill
you go to sly for 62.
it says aha no yes go back up so go back
to 62. the blue line in this chart just
shows the fed's balance sheet as a
percent of public debt outstanding they
have to pay the bill and and you think
about the change in the fed's
composition over the next year so you
know you could have a different fat head
although i don't think we're going to
but you could have six new people on the
fomc board all could be you know pretty
uh dovish on a relative to basis to the
the current composition of the board
although we will get two hawks at the
margin but
you know this this fed could be very
different over the next three to five
years in terms of facilitating this
lurching left of fiscal policy as a
function of not just together but for
some of these dynamics that have been
building up these vulnerabilities that
have been building up for 20 years